[Music]
chess and psychology and or said there
actually and I just wanted to thank
everyone who participated in the poll
today because I had some ideas that I
wanted to do and I just wanted to see
what people want and it was pretty cool
to see a very nice divided the results
were 38% middle game 30% endgame and 31%
the opening Lasker gambit defense that I
wanted to show so so here we are and I
decided to go with a nice blend of
middle game and end game so we could
just get back to it and just think more
oh no you missed the pole well where I
like doing polls every for every class
so just like there is a everyone gets a
little pumped about what to do so yeah
okay so I found some pretty cool Fischer
puzzles so these are from Fischer games
and these are all of them Fischer won so
that should give you a pretty clear idea
on what moves to look for so yeah just
think about that a little bit and okay
so hello from California cool I'm
reading the chat but I might fall behind
a little class talking and trying to
keep up is not always the easiest job
okay so let's jump into the positions
and the first one we have student coming
up there the first one is a game between
Fischer
um pour it give me a second
pour of job I believe and this is in
1962 so
oh hi from Norway and Sweden cool I've
been to New Orleans never Sweden I
didn't want to play the tournament in
Sweden but somehow never happened all
right so here is white to move and just
think what you want to do so some of it
is easy but be careful cuz just make
sure you think about the whole position
and not just few pieces cause okay
this night is kind of Panda
you see the Queen is under attack but
you can't really like take it's because
the night is fine right
so yeah just think a little about this
position make sure you consider how weak
this King is also that you have extra
piece on the board and yeah keep typing
in the chat about what you would want to
do and we'll just go from there make
sure you think about tanks or possible
checks checks are cool to end up in
mates right yeah so sacking the Queen is
something that you should definitely
think about but make sure you actually
like so what would you do if he takes
the Queen because sometimes it's
sacrifice sometimes suggests blunder so
hopefully we're not blundering right all
right um yeah cool I remember you the I
remember the this the username because
of the cool anime and you've you've said
cool stuff before - you were right just
- super Korra you're right yeah so
Bishop g7 is the best one good job you
everyone
okay so the idea is Bishop g7 if you
were to take the f6 and you can't really
stop to mate and if the King were to
just take on g7 you would simply just
pick up this pawn it's possible to do it
with the Queen - because there is no
more attack on c3 and you're just a
piece up so first of all it's pretty
easy right okay um let's go to the next
one okay um
right here that full oven works yay whoa
New Zealand Wow
some lot of places I've never been hello
okay so let's think about this a little
bit why to move how would you want to
continue you remember whitefish deer
Fisher's always been in writes Algeria
Wow
so let's see
okay yeah you're correct shanks well
going pretty fast okay so taking on f7
is pretty cool because after take you
just have to remember not to just take
it back immediately because well that
kind of defeats the whole idea and you
want to play Queen c4 and make sure that
you do this you are bringing more
pressure and you are just kind of
provoking this 95 because it's also the
only move and that kind of tries to hold
the position otherwise it's just clean
up seven coming up in 96 and it's
already pretty horrifying so and you
just pick up the exchange and if after
take you just pick up the other piece
too so
pretty cool huh okay so Portugal I've
actually been to Portugal never more eco
and also never island Wow a lot of it's
very global here alright let's go to the
next one okay so here is also wise to
move and so I have a little bit of
commentary over this so while you guys
are thinking about what to do I'll just
tell you a little story about Fisher so
like in 1964 Fisher went on the road and
played simultaneous all over the US for
those of you who are not in the US and
this was in a book called van during
King I actually unfortunately never read
that book but I heard about it so and so
yeah not everybody who played against
him in simultaneous we're good but it
gave a pretty cool position for us right
so winner six looks like mates right but
can you try and give me the mate right
it's a its mate in five and
congratulations to those of you who
thought about cleaning six it's pretty
cool that's pretty
it's good that you're thinking about
checks and takes and yeah all right
let's see what shanks is saying we have
queer sex take check King g6 Bishop h5
King engage six or seven Bishop f7 yes
you are right yeah good job all right
it's perfect
thank you I'm just gonna show it on the
board as well I don't know why YouTube
keeps hiding stuff for review YouTube
alright so after check and you end up in
this position with mate which is pretty
cool
obviously she doesn't matter don't beat
yourself up it's I mean you see that the
King doesn't have anywhere to go and
there is no way to actually stop it so
do we get either this mates too
so good job everyone and yeah let's rock
and roll
okay this one's white - move - is Fisher
versus Winston this was in US champs
1960 so here is another cool thing about
history okay so I'm not gonna give you
you out too much but you can clearly see
that white has a pretty organized attack
and this King looks pretty sad and ready
to be mated so just think about how you
can bring in more force yeah I'm gonna
get like oops about like thirty seconds
so everyone has a chance to just absorb
the position a little bit but I'm
reading the comments York you guys are
correct
but so um yeah good it's the technique
of trying to the way I call it
distracting the defense the defensive
piece
so this jerk is defending v8 and you
would want this route to go away so you
take on edge six provoke the rope to
move away and yeah you all right Andrew
even if fruit goes to e8 that doesn't
really work because it's just picky six
up yeah queen of six is pretty sweet
right hand mates okay um Fischer has
some cool games right okay so this one
it's black to move its Rivera versus
Fischer Olympia 1962 and now this one
was a little bit trickier but this is a
concept that I kind of emphasize on a
lot and the concept of like the hanging
pieces or the defenseless pieces or the
ones that are dropping a little bit you
know those kind of pieces so do you see
anything like that in this position oh
you selfish or play in 1972
Wow that is pretty cool Oh Marco you
were right so are so are you shanks all
right I'm gonna give it like just 30
seconds so everyone she can just get a
good grip of this position and but yeah
it's pretty cool thank you for
participating
but yeah you see these two bishops are
already looking like hey can attack me
especially this one that looks like a
tall pawn let me rephrase that tall
weird pawn so yeah you kind of want to
come and attack this and that's the
whole idea
so you go clean c6 you put you clean on
b5 and even if like there's nothing to
do like just look at this position for a
second if you touch this Bishop anywhere
this Bishop falls if you don't touch
this Bishop well this Bishop is falling
Queen c6 and clean beef I was kind of
brilliant idea hopefully you all would
have found this in a real game
any questions never been good ok let's
jump to the next one
oh we got a rush of ski Fischer in 1970s
so for I I think this was the last round
of the US Championship I think yeah
loose pieces drop oh thank you LPD oh
yeah so lol does should be our Chester
right okay um yeah cool you Marco you're
pretty good what's your rating
okay so Queen d4 is the same concept
that you do this Queen d4 check fortune
is keen to go away and then you do clean
up too so now you are kind of forcing
this king them to just just be punished
for being so bad in the first rank right
and if take holders rookie one if Y
tries to defend this with Queen B 5 it
doesn't really work cuz well Ricky one
right so this is another concept that is
pretty easy and we see in Grandmaster
games such as Reshevsky they also kind
of slightly mess it up what about Queen
III Queen e1 I think Queen III the issue
is that okay so if you do Queen f2 is
kind of the same thing but what if they
do recover to here I mean yeah you could
oh no be careful with the EA track um
but okay let's say for if just King is
one Queen even what about just Queen b5
defending it
I mean there's rookie too but again
drugs she won I feel like he would on
make it a little complicated unnecessary
that's that or which I was Queen of two
or queen you want oh wait hold on
Queenie one isn't there this yeah I mean
you're not losing but now you are so
okay yeah Queen f7 good good I everyone
catch it nice yeah Queenie one it
doesn't necessarily work because you are
just blundering it and good guy cool
alright so another thing I was just
trying to look at it as just a practical
point not just the calculation and the
problem is that you couldn't bring in
yours rook necessarily oh no this wasn't
a zonal oh so what the last round of the
US Championship ma'am
alright well I know there is a game in
here that was the last round of the US
Championship but okay so yeah just
practically between III and Queen e1 it
would make it kind of weird because even
if Queen f7 didn't work how can you
bring in your rook whereas when you're
Queen was on on f2 then you have this
rook e1 which is pretty deadly right and
um what about cleaning of - why not
rogue g1 so if cleanup two rooks you
want well it's still rook e1 yeah you
can't really get away with it okay so
this was a cool one he thought it would
be a little easier but okay let's look
at the next one alright now we have a
Spassky Fischer Game five of World
Championship 1972 Fischer is black again
and so this is the match that happened
in Iceland and yeah
was kind of a cool match I also watched
the the movie that they made not
necessarily the actors didn't really
impress me but the whole the whole thing
really did
oh I see they're already moves coming up
in the chat okay um so for those of you
who are seeing it's super quick
brilliant you are gold but for those of
you who are not seeing it as fast one
way to think about it is so but you can
clearly see that black has a better
spatial advantage and there are more
things that black is targeting right so
just think about it
if if I could bring the Queen over here
this Queen of the Night would be very in
a good rhythm with attacking here and
then that poor guy so that's something
that you could just think about it
and so here's Fischer is black and
Fischer did this Bishop a4 so the idea
is pretty simple if you take it well I'm
just gonna pick this up and well whoops
and this will actually result in a win
but what if black like white doesn't
take if white doesn't take and play
something like trying to defend this
still you can just easily exchange it
and just take over they're still trying
to mate and the bishop is under attack
so it's kind of hard to defend it I mean
I mean it's possible to try and defend
but it doesn't necessarily work because
you're dropping all of your pawns and
just your king is weak your Bishop is
kind of weird-looking place and it is
winning enough yeah everything is
falling right okay so glad to be agree
on that and okay so let's look at the
next one because I'm actually curious to
know where is this year's champ ah this
is the u.s. job game first year receptor
chefs key u.s. champ 1958 there we go
this was the decisive game for the title
of u.s. championship
10:58 Fisher must have been a baby yeah
yeah all right so what do you think baby
Fisher did here why to move this is a
beautiful one so well hmm I was kind of
I was kind of gonna say wait like 20
seconds but any well you are too good
here you're too good to soup up around
your to wait a good cool
four out of you keep it up all right so
let's see if everybody sees it so make
sure you do consider checks and takes
and yeah checks and tags and how black
is underdeveloped and how you would want
to just ideally punish him for being
underdeveloped you know the usual stuff
or yeah the Fisher trap huh okay so
let's see um okay but I know that you
guys see the trap but what if I before I
show it so for those of you who are
already thinking
please continue thinking but for those
of you who are already set Bishop of
seven and ninety six I agree with Chef
of seven if rook F seven lights ecigs
and easy-peasy
right what if Bishop of seven King F 796
then the King takes so can you just try
and tell me the mate after that it's a
nice challenge on it so give a little
bit more time for the other people who
are just catching up so so yes the first
one is about seven and regardless of
taking with Bishop ordered King White is
going to play this 96 right but my
question is if 96 King e6 okay
well yeah we would want to checkmate the
King right so Queen d5 makes sense right
and the King has to go to f5 what else
can
someone just give me the mate after can
get five its mate in the one two three
four five
all right so g4 is good let me show it
over here what after g4 so let's say g4
King takes g4 okay so back to here if
through things just ninety-six and voila
and if white if black just takes it with
the King you can't simply play this and
now we're talking about King e6 because
if details X is just you pick up the
clean and you can tank your opponents
and that I believe that was it was a
very cool way to get the US Championship
title for baby Fisher he was a baby back
then okay so back to King takes a six it
is important to actually calculate this
before you play it because you I mean
you have a feeling it's made but you
want to be sure you don't want the
opponent to be able to slip away so
Queen d5 King up g4 king g4 is the only
move legal move okay so why to move what
do you want to do now okay so we got the
g4 and there is a rook Jiwon - okay
if King goes back to f5 that's one
possibility
tella possibility is king gauge for or
king gauge five so
um let's first look yeah you can get
five is work g5 mates but what if King
edge five oh no
King gauge five there we go so what
would you do after King is five King f5
without God it's rook g5 and cool but
what if King edge five can get five I
think this is well there's a check there
there's another check there there's
another trick there so one two three
yeah that's what I'm thinking Queen D
one is definitely made but I was trying
to see if there is a faster way cuz if
Queen D one King edge for Bishop g5
kingís tree Queen g4 and queen g2 mate
but is there a is there faster way what
if EC snot you six forget five kind of
creeps me out a little
it gives a drug coming in I mean it's
too late because if you still have Queen
d1 and Queen g4 okay no just Queen D
Wondrich after you take Queen D one if
you can get for you just to queen g4
mates so no need to yeah major -
easy-peasy nothing easier than that
there's no maintain one so cool we got
this so what about English for so whoa
chad is going way too fast
yeah that's pretty much the same you
just have to be sure to do this Bishop
g5 if King goes to h5 you do the Queen
d1 one away
if King goes to whoops if King goes to
where's the edge tree I just do the
Queen g2 way and yeah well I really like
this one it was a pretty cool one we got
to sharpen our instinct and use some
calculation okay let's keep going oh we
got another Fischer Spassky game
9 this was if I'm correct 1992 yeah
the rematch yep so that's super high
prize fund well super high back then
let's call it I mean it's still pretty
high
I wouldn't mind kissing that much money
you know anyways so this one is white to
move and so after seeing the polls I
need I knew I had to include some and
game in that cuz people
the polls are really close I really
thought there would be like a decisive
one but oh boy okay so now this is all
grown up Fisher no more baby Fisher
Debbie Fisher was pretty cool yeah
c5 is kind of under attack on the fire
and those rook and Knight on G and s
shade are just like homeboy so um cancer
can someone just give me a little bit
more like okay so a nice e5 take okay
six okay yeah that's pretty good
take if you were to take with if you
were to take back just for k-6
and d6 right this should get it done and
yeah yeah great and if Bishop CH I mean
I thought this was kind of weird because
he just lose the pond anyways and you're
just putting your Bishop back to ca - it
didn't make much sense but well they
like this and to no one's surprise
Fischer did manage to win this end game
and all right so anyone have a question
on this one because it was a pretty cool
one but I understand if there are
questions
okay so yeah under developments
I think oh yeah this is the pretty long
one so this was a game between Fisher
and Phillip in 1962 there were so many
games in 1962 that had so much tactic in
it by the way is there anyone here who
hasn't actually read the 16 memorable
game by Fisher because if you have not
oh my god go get on it you got one week
to do all 60 games they're very nice
it's Fisher written it and he talked
about his own ideas and what he was
thinking about
oh no sign oh no wow why are you you why
you were so good - super Carell why you
oh my god all right guys you go get on
it should be your first book to read
after this you know the book no summer
course is nothing you got to do that
it's a really good one who's to move
it's white Timmy huh I mean I read it a
few times and I don't necessarily
memorize it so I haven't I don't
remember every single game but they were
really good games in there that's just
60 games but yeah you can't I'm sure you
can find it online - yep
that's usually my first advice for
reading book because puzzles are cool
but it's like puzzles you just feel like
it's like you're reading it and moving
on breathing moving on like solving
that's it but when you're looking at a
full game that the person who played the
game did the commentaries on it
you kind of get a better feeling you
connect better you understand better
yeah why not game changer I mean no I
don't remember that book if that that's
a book okay so the title of the book its
Fisher wrote this book and he called it
my sixteen memorable games and
apparently he wanted to be 64 because of
the 64 squares in chessboard but he kind
of didn't like the last four games other
book recommendations any book you find
that has commentary units from ideally
the players who did it
those are good books I believe pretty
much every world champion has one oh
yeah yeah I really liked the Kasparov
great predecessors too for 1400 it might
be too strong but I started reading
though I started reading these books
when I was like 10 and I didn't really I
mean as long as you understand chess
notation and you understand something
from the book you should you should read
it
yeah and yes to recreate but what if
okay a truck g3 another great book was
the Zurich tournament 1953 but make sure
you find the one with the commentary my
other favorite books that I sometimes
use some ideas from for dis classes too
and I actually did one game from them
was the Giants of strategy I did my
video about how to beat Kasparov in 13
steps from that iron viscous barf so
that's not saying I did but it was the
title from the game in the book and I
really enjoyed that that was a game
between Karpov and Kasparov yeah
those are some of just the cool stuff
that I remember there are so many other
new books to look into as well but those
are kind of the classic ones that I like
the girl font three books well I don't
I'm not sure if the third one came out
but only the first and second one that I
read they were pretty amazing too okay
back to the game glad we got some book
stuff out of the way so yes rookie eight
is the first move you should think about
and the best move for black is your g3
but what after rook jittery so Knight f4
interesting but before I say yes or no
can you let me know what if Knight went
to e3
so what's wrong with 93 basically well I
said it's wrong so
nice III can't block somehow try to
sleep away get some checks out of this
yeah - five workers five does look
pretty painful right okay so yes tonight
III Turk it's five and yes to it being
painful so ninth floor is the best way
to play but just looking at it is pretty
hard to make the decision because you
don't listen you just want a piece
why would you want to give it back right
so okay so let's look at night at four
whoa someone already looked up stuff on
the book cool glad you guys worked so
fast okay so back at its Knight to f4
let's say black just takes whoa nice
ninety-two you guys are very good so
wreckage turns pretty much to only move
right kingi - now you'll have to sink
for black
what if black plays rook f h4 or give
you check on drew h2 so can you give me
a little bit of just ideas or lines on
both of these so what if you're close to
h2 check or what if black plays through
h4 rook f h4 Wow where is this going
oh my god where's my mouse oh there's
mouse but it so that's the first
question and that's the second question
okay so rue cash - yeah king goes to g3
agreed on that but then it'll close to
f7
what's now
I shouldn't show who was the opponent
why not you just want to know who
Fischer you just want to know Fischer
was white or black
yep Brooke if one is the best one good
good and you managed to get the piece
all right cool great so let's go back to
not check and whatever goes to h4
so it fruit goes to h4 what do you think
white should do
nice gee what 95 I think there might be
a slight delay okay so that's I don't
think that counts Knight f4 looks
interesting but Knight f4
I mean Knight f4 there's a chance for
just what if just wreckage - King up
just night saves the night just stay
safe somewhere g5 maybe maybe here I I
don't know it just
I'm not the biggest fan of my King King
a little just right here but I yeah I'm
thinking what if like no that doesn't
work I was thinking with my t2 to try
and create checks but I mean nice 85
looks pretty cool
trying to come over here maybe throwing
in ig4 here maybe a 96 trying to
exchange just keeping some options open
okay um 94 does look good though
but rook t6 is the best one
what did I miss in the chance
did I miss anything in the chat
ah people hmm okay well thank you Thank
You Sammy we'll take that under
consideration
okay so sorry after 56 what do you want
to do because you see Ricky seven rusty
eight mate is coming up so
Knight f4
um it's it is black to move though okay
90 yuan chick thank you no we're not
there to resign yet um be careful rook G
for you would be slightly um blundering
this a little bit okay um no black
counts still fights both white is
definitely better so you can't just play
91 oh hi I've been to Philippines cool
okay so after 91 what do you think
should happen hold on I'm still thinking
about something I said I might have said
it wrong I was Catholic okay let's just
continue with this we'll go back after
okay so here let's say after a night you
want check black a whites gotta play
King if one and after it can get one
what do you want to do now so I see a
rookie d3 rook d3 is a good idea
what about stroke each one crooks d3o
hold on could I take the knight on f3 oh
yeah I don't know why I might have I
probably was thing I don't know why I
didn't whoa well thank you for
correcting me dearly
alright so but here what do you want to
do here would whack after king f1
yeah haruka chuan is one way york t3 is
another way let's look at Rick t3
because Rick t3 just check and he takes
c6 and again rook is going back for c8
mate right so I don't this is a little
too too hard to call it's too slippery
for blacks to be able to actually save
it I don't think I can say this even if
I cook the eights try and stop the mate
it's still you're losing this guy see
this time I remember to eat the piece
yay three pieces are usually good stuff
you usually want to eat you for the free
pieces right all right oh yeah I crash
me my queen was almost trapped but
somehow its ran away so what about
storage one you got to do King gift to
check King up another check let's say
King e4 so after qg7 actually they kind
of stopped and resigned and just Fischer
won so I'm so do you guys feel the needs
to continue over here and see what's
going on because I mean it's not mating
two or three but you can definitely just
start by checking and just you can put
this rug anywhere and you're still doing
the mates threat so something like
Heaney eight should be happening but
then you eat this guy and then you go
the other way so it's the problem is
that black can't really stop to mate so
just wanted to ask if you guys feel
comfortable went up about this I just
put this rook all the way back there
same same concept you want to tuck the
rook in and bring up the other guy to
wrap it up
okay um yeah
Oh Indonesia cool okay I kind of want to
go back because I feel like I made weird
comments which don't know why I did so
let's go back was it here that I was
talking about check yeah check up nope
not this check oh yeah here we were
talking about might a for and I said
check and well I mean take that I don't
know why I let's just call it the brain
freeze and move on whoops but seriously
after nine to four months should black
do I'm thinking I don't really see any
cool checks to try to stop it I mean
technically theoretically black could
just take over here and try to just sit
and wait try to eat some more pawns and
see how it goes and yeah I mean it's
like four pawns okay let's say we take
this take that still pretty
uncomfortable still dismayed coming up
no I mean this is a still winning for
white so Nyjah forced polish would have
worked as well but it might have just
been better to just play straight 56 and
just go for the jugular basically
alright so sorry for the little hiccup
sometimes I see free pizzas and I'm like
now who likes these free pieces alright
let's look at the other one oh this is a
cool one too okay so what do we want to
do here why it's to move let's think at
least 30 seconds before just shooting at
moose I know you will see it I know you
all want to take stuff and eat stuff and
give checks and sack and everything but
anyone feels like a fool line and just a
heads up it's not and it's not like a
fast mate or anything it's just a cool
position okay so this game is between
Fisher and Daly in nineteen eight sixty
seven all right so
oh hi are I'm sure go ahead why not 30
seconds are up
all right so we like this trick f8 good
and the good thing is the Queen has two
tanks of the queen is going all the way
back to f8 so now what what do you want
to do after Queen takes epic I know you
guys see it if King takes f8 you just
take the Queen good um t-shirt Delhi I
hope I have this I was on there Fisher
yeah Delhi that's good to know you guys
are Fisher fans too or at least if not
fans you at least know his is games
right
okay group thing one is cool but you
could think of something a little bit
more forceful because your key one what
if Joe's Queen comes to e7 Queen I for
ya and b5 is pretty
I mean b5 kinda has to happen right
because if King e7 Bishop c5 15 f7 or
kf1 King d8 I mean can I just play your
key one and thank him
so b5 clean e4 is pretty forceful
so after Queenie for let's say we're
close to the eights now what's now what
how do you want to wrap the game up
Queenie for well I thought I said Connie
for but well yep thank you thank you
Haruka f1 it's interesting but yeah
Queen c6 should be pretty pretty
forceful and let's call it Burke d7 now
what's so earth d7 what do you want to
do now
first eat one yeah I think if t1 should
be pretty doable right birthday woman
and so now Queen e7 is forced so now
just one remove and it would be pretty
cool
oh hold on hold on Bishop g5 does give a
little chance for a little wiggle room
so be careful all right so let's look at
Bishop g5 first if I played Bishop g5
black does have one move that Chi it's I
mean it's not it's not like a saving
move but it's it kind of slips away
making the game a little longer
can anyone try to find that for black
and yes Bishop c5 was kind of cool
Bishop b6 is even better or rook t3
that's also pretty cool but oh I'm still
not seeing this move no no no no it's
white it's black to move after Bishop g5
no wow I'm not seeing this holiday well
no you don't want to lose your king
right oh my god I see this Wow Peter Pan
whoa all right so just castle and it's
just worth mentioning it's nothing super
duper but it is kind of interesting to
look at because I mean this is a still
seat because you can't really take it
right down because well whoops
can I take that please oh come on come
on drunk there we go
you're right it's pretty SuperDuper
right so I think my Queen d7 has to
happen and then Queen g5 and then Queen
e6 and see black is is still slipping
away why this is still better but black
is kind of being slippery what is the
psychology relationship I don't just
give up puzzles I try to actually
explain that what how you should think
about it and well today wasn't as deep
for psychology I agree with that
but I don't really like to give out like
just puzzles and be like oh it's a
dessert at puzzles good luck everyone
but yeah I like doing just talking
through it and not eating pieces as I
did today pretty cool right now usually
like I've been doing this like opening
related series just trying to explain
from my experience and mixing it up it
some you know super GM experiences and
games and talking a little bit deeper
about openings and how like this opening
is a little bit more annoying and this
has like this little trick in it those
are what I was kind of thinking about
please mention if Queen c5 was played
where oh thank you thank you guys could
you let me know where Queen c5 also they
didn't spoil Fisher didn't play Bishop
g5 in the game I think picture of Fisher
poised rook to e3 and they just resigned
because now Bishop g5 is coming
but hold on one after Bishop c5 put
there still be castle that's um
Castle hmm because you still can't take
the Queen so I think Bishop c5 wouldn't
work because of again Castille right
yeah either Bishop c5 and Bishop g5
don't work because of castle there was
the Bishop b6 mentioned so um this
should be six was also mentioned there's
a cool move and now if I cast oh well
okay you just pick this rock up and
orbit the Queen and this is a totally
winning in the game right okay um if
here wait actually Bishop c5 Castle 57
there are no checks or takes yeah Bishop
c5 I mean okay Bishop g5 is a bad move
because of castle we established that
but if Bishop c5 mmm Castle just take
the rook with drug d7 Queen f6 still
take on f8 and there are no me not any
traps so yeah that works yes
Bishop c5 I'm thinking is there anything
maybe just Queen f7 but then just Queen
c8 and that's kind of the end of that so
what about Queen d8 still Queen d6
Bishop c5 actually does what about
Bishop c5 Queen c5 check though does
that try to get away a little because
you do have to take and then check and I
mean look at fate
it does feel like black is getting some
game so I don't think Bishop c5 Castille
doesn't work with Bishop c5 Queen c5
does work so be careful with these
little things so I think rukh d3 it's
pretty cool because you're just waiting
but Bishop b6 is also very interesting
because now you are actually threatening
Queen c8 as well and yeah so the key in
this position isn't to just rush into
Bishop g5 or Bishop c5 it's more into
trying and just keeping your cool and
just allowing your opponents to make
mistake like playing with Bishop b6 or
Bishop microcut III as happen in the
game so any more questions from this
position all right okay um I don't know
how much time we get left
oh okay well I guess we were wrapping up
whoa the time flew well thank you for
everyone who joined us and stayed and
did the poll too and yeah well I'm gonna
give you to another slew student daro
have fun with him and make sure to come
to ladies night on Thursday
on Twitch and I'll see you on YouTube
next week have fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you